how big a deal is this I remember this
was a story when Tessa was hustling
within Jersey as well right well if
everything's bigger in Texas this is
probably a big deal I mean this is the
second-biggest car market in America
that is shut off to Tesla and so it's
it's not insignificant and Texas is not
alone if you look at the map across the
country of all the places that Tesla's
are unable to be sold to people who want
to go buy a car Tesla car not only is it
not a few places but they're fairly
popular states like Michigan like
Connecticut like Arizona so these are
significant places in place that that
Tesla is sort of failing to lift the
sales bans and it's limiting the ability
to sell Tesla why is it you know messing
with Texas I mean the the the dealers
the existing dealers in Texas certainly
have a lot of power in that state but
the the bill has now failed to get any
sort of traction there it doesn't isn't
it said they're not only are they gonna
be unable to sell them they couldn't
even get the bill introduced into both
houses in Texas and now they're done for
the year it's the second biggest auto
market behind California as I mentioned
and they've spent a lot of money on
lobbyists they're just in the fourth
quarter alone they spent over $150,000
on 20 lobbyists in Texas so it wasn't
for lack of trying that they couldn't
get this through even get to get a vote
on it whatsoever hey Cory so what's a
workaround here I mean we can't assume
that there's no Tesla in Texas well you
know that's just the thing so the the
Bears look at this and say hey why isn't
Tesla stock down when they're losing out
of the second biggest market in America
their most important country at least
historically the Bulls look at this and
say hey when the doors finally open in
Texas it'll be great for them the
problem with that is it
Tesla themselves say that are twenty
five hundred people in Texas who've
bought Tesla's in other states and
driven them in or had them imported in
some way so there already are Tesla's in
Texas it's not a virgin market to them
but it's a market that's hard for them
to reach in size in any way as the Model
S gets older and older and longer on the
tooth I mean certainly Tesla wants to
change this but to what extent doesn't
really need to change just given that so
much of its growth or what it wants to
see the growth in is overseas yeah
overseas have been so important to tests
in the last few quarters particularly of
all play
this is Norway there have been
tremendous incentives to buy in Norway
better parking places fast lanes but
those incentives look like they're gonna
evaporate probably they may have already
done so in April maybe as late as May
because a certain number of electric
vehicles we're going to be I get these
benefits and it looks like Norway's
already imported that many cars so the
growth rate for Tesla which was boosted
by these kinds of things has really come
off a lot growing only at 2%
sequentially so they sold more cars last
quarter than ever before but only 2
percent more and not their inability to
break into new markets the the the
disappearing of subsidies in foreign
markets it could have a serious impact
on Tesla going forward